fighting words which is the kind of
thing speech that's not protected by the
First Amendment Cato's libertarian not
conservative and I think that that falls
under fighting words we're not going to
call the police in this case but but
it's an important distinction fight
averted I think it's absolutely right
that public school so as government
entities are often way too inclined to
curb basic expression rights I think
that is very clear in this book if
you're not clear on that already read
the book you will be but we also I think
have to be clear about two things and
these these are concerns I have about
the book one public schools are often as
I think professor been poor 'litham
talked about they're not actually often
thought of as sort of training places
for us to work at our differences or as
you say places I thought this is a great
quote learning liberty by living it I
think that people tend to not look at
schools that way this is why this topic
I think doesn't come up that much and
second it concerns me the use of the
term democracy and it's not just in your
book it's throughout any education fight
or any education discussion or debate
and I'll get into a little bit more
about why I think the use of the term is
problematic for the first point though I
think that if you even read the major
advocates of public schooling sort of
historically they weren't all that
interested in again learning liberty by
living it as something that the schools
were primarily about they were more
about shaping people I think from above
so Benjamin Rush is a pretty well-known
founding father big in Philadelphia big
in Pennsylvania he was really an early
advocate of widespread public schooling
and he said he you should create a
public schooling system that would quote
render the mass of the people more
homogeneous and thereby fit them more
easily for uniform and peaceable
government and he talked about teaching
sort of inculcating common morals so it
wasn't really about people sort of
themselves getting together talking
about their differences it was more will
take sort of an elite notion of what a
proper citizen is make people sort of
identical and there we
have problems when they're older and
they're able to have Liberty horse man
often called the father of the public
schools or the common schools of
godfather become schools no matter what
name you give him he was privy leading
advocate for for public schooling in the
1830s 1840s and he talked about public
schooling not really again about
bringing in diverse people to work out
their differences and to talk about what
made them difference but making them
sort of similar sort of you know people
who held the same sort of elite views
that he did he talked about diffusing
general intelligence - but it was really
about inculcating common morality and it
was a common morality that I think he
hoped was held by people a lot like him
if you go will go just to the the
Progressive Era so the turn of the
twentieth century just as one more
example Elwood Cubberley was a very
well-known public schooling thinker an
advocate and again a lot he and a lot of
people who were like him didn't
necessarily see the schools as a place
where you learn liberty in fact he said
quote we should give up the exceedingly
democratic idea that all are equal and
that our society is devoid of classes
the employee tends to remain an employee
the wage earner tends to remain a wage
earner and this was the period of using
IQ test to decide well your future is in
a factory and maybe for a small percent
your future is in college and this again
so wasn't really oriented toward our
public schools are where we learned to
be citizens who have equal rights with
everyone else and we work out our
differences ourselves certainly some
public schooling advocates did want that
and we and professor Ben port already
talked about John Dewey he was much more
in this mold of we have schools where
kids would come together from different
backgrounds and they'd work on sort of
projects together and they would learn
to live together and it's sort of a
different view than this kind of
top-down notion I think was more a
driver of public schooling this idea
that we should sort of shape people in a
way to be kind of uniform and again the
discussion it seems to me of even those
goals today has been you know fifth or
sixth or seventh or nine hundredths per
hour
next to test scores test scores test
scores that I think is what in many
cases we have reduced education to being
then just talk a little bit about the
term democracy and this comes up a lot
for me and I think it's very important
how we use it and it's often sort of
used interchangeably to mean a lot of
things that can mean representative
government to some people it can be kind
of a leveling of people it can people
can say it as synonymous with individual
liberty sometimes for people it means
majority rule often it means just from
some way public control or public rule
and this latter notion I think kind of
drives a common belief when we get
beyond the test doors that public
schools should basically respond to
whatever the community however you
define that community once usually its
whoever is being represented by that
school board and that leads to a
fundamental clash about what the schools
do the individual rights versus the
community values a lot of this you know
sociologists know people say education
is about social reproduction so the
community says this is how we shape
students to be part of our community our
society and that means they have to
share our norms and values and not do
things that concern us I think you can
see that most clearly and sort of Morse
be Frederick it may be because nobody
ever forgets bong hits for Jesus so you
remember that case there's another you
go back to colonial eras
another law no one's ever heard of but I
think they never forget after I tell
them they say the first law for public
schools was called the old deluder Satan
act so if you can get Jesus or Satan in
the name of the law or in a court case
people remember it in any event I think
ultimately there there's a fundamental
problem especially if we talk about
Democratic control this idea that we
should have some sort of public control
it's inherently conflictual the
conflicts cannot be escaped and now I'm
gonna do sort of a shameless plug well
not really that shameless but we run
something called the public schooling
battle map and I think it's about to go
up behind me I never rely on my own
ability to operate anything there we go
so the public schooling battle map the
reason it's here is is it it's supposed
to sort of illustrate
people how many sort of conflicts we
have in public schools there this
doesn't include about well how do you
teach multiplication or you know what's
the right day to start the school year
what hour do we start the school day
this is about values and identity based
conflicts that we have in public schools
and the reason it tends to be inherently
conflictual is that you have diverse
people use their their ideologically
diverse linguistically diverse
ethnically diverse religiously diverse
but they are all ultimately supporting
one system and we're trying to get this
system to to to treat them or to educate
them all but one system can't teach
everything that everybody wants and so
you can see this it can be deceptive
just to look at it so they're actually
way more conflicts than you see here
because a lot of those little pins bury
other pins but if you were to pull out
you'd also it would look less intense
and you think they're a lot of places
where nobody lives for instance no no
markers there but they're there a lot of
place where there are people if you
don't see one of these and as you talked
about in the book you know what makes it
two courts and often what makes it into
the media it's not every conflict that
we have probably it's a tip of the
iceberg so this may just be the tip of
the iceberg but the point here is to
illustrate that we're constantly having
conflicts over all sorts of issues and I
think the best illustration maybe is if
you think of library books and on page
101 a professor Ross's book she notes
that schools can choose to buy any book
they want or not buy any book they want
for whatever reason but if you get into
the removal of a book you say that a
parent says well I don't think that this
book is appropriate in the middle school
library or I don't think this should be
on my child's reading list that becomes
a constitutional issue of is this
government censorship if you remove it
we concede the problems should the
government be able to favor speech for
whatever reason it wants so it deems
this book is worthy of having kids read
it or putting it library this book over
here this speech over here is not worthy
of being in the library and that is
inherently conflictual and so we have on
the map just to it
the incredible power of the map and user
friendliness there we go is these are
all the book banning reading material
conflicts we have again probably tip of
the iceberg but they're about 220 of
these and this is only this is collected
over maybe ten years we started in 2005
some of them reached farther back but
it's just things that I we see in the
news and we pull out here but that's
inherently conflictual 220 of these is
it unjust ultimately you compel support
for those who would not choose to pay
for say Robert Cormier it's the
chocolate war you may not have read it
but that's one of the most challenged
books or what about people say I don't
think I should pay for or I don't think
my children should have to read The
Adventures of Huckleberry Finn well how
do you bounce it what the people say yes
these are very valuable books to read
government one way or another is making
the decision what to read or what not to
read we've also talked about human
origins everybody knows creation versus
evolution but inherently there is a
problem it leads to inequality so if you
teach evolution alone automatically
creationists feel like they're
second-class citizens and you might even
say it's religious discrimination that
they can't have their viewpoint in there
also but you add creationism and you're
injecting religion which is certainly
something that we don't want government
to do so you can't treat all these
people equally also I think a couple
more just small critiques
well it's crucially important to protect
speech and and I think professor ben
porous talked about this a little so I
won't go into it too much but I think
there is a good argument especially for
teachers people you know in the
classroom every day for saying you've
got to have a lot of discipline even if
it means people's speech goes way
because it can be very difficult to
teach what you need to teach to run a
classroom if you don't have that and
even if someone is saying something that
is perfectly legitimate viewpoint you
can't have your 45 minutes devolve into
a debate about something when you need
to cover other material both for
educational purposes and of course for
testing purposes you've always got to
cover other material and then finally I
think there's something important about
shared norms and beliefs I think
research by James Coleman and others
have shown that private schools
especially religious schools
may in fact outperform public schools
because ultimately everyone who goes to
that school accepts the school's norms
and values and that creates sort of
cohesion you don't have to have as we
see in public schools sort of rule by
law and regulation and often a muddling
through as you illustrate very well in
the book we're not really sure what to
do how do we decide on what policy to
have or how to treat this student when
we know to make some people in the
community angry and others won't like
what I do if I don't punish the student
in private schooling everybody you agree
basically what the handbook says and
that enables the school to run much more
coherently and cohesively and it maybe
leads to better academic outcomes I
don't want to say that I think that this
is slam dunk research but there is some
research to show this and I think that
given the inherent conflict of public
schooling the only way to truly treat
people equally and protect them from
government incursions on their rights
speech rights religious rights etc is
educational freedom ultimately attach
money to students not to specific
schools and give educators freedom to
start the kinds of schools they want
with the policies they want with the
curriculum they want and let those
people freely interact and so somebody
who wants maximum expression rights in
the school can choose a school like that
somebody who says no I want sort of the
no excuses
tough discipline you may be not even
speaking in the cafeteria kind of
atmosphere they can choose that as well
and then if you're not happy if you say
I chose a school that doesn't have a
strict anti-bullying policy because I
want maximum freedom but my child is
getting bullied to the point I can't
tolerate it you can also leave that
school and that's just you point out in
the book that's a problem with public
schools is in a way you're a captive
audience this gives you an ability to
escape and you could choose schools for
any other number of reasons not just
these policies so in that sort of case
government wouldn't decide on speech
rights or religious rights or anything
else
parents would make those decisions and
it could even as I said go elsewhere if
they're unhappy so I think it's
absolutely important
to understand the threats to freedom of
speech and other freedoms and how to
minimize them in public schools I think
this book does an absolutely terrific
job of talking about those issues diving
into him talking about how to resolve
them I especially like your chart which
I'm going to put up in my office for
anyone a cup says stuff I don't like but
I think it's even more important
ultimately to move to a system on which
those kinds of threats can be escaped by
the people that the education system is
supposed to serve thank you Neil's
comment about the distinction between
conservatives and libertarians reminded
me of my old friend Walter burns book
freedom virtue in the First Amendment
which goes back to the 1950s you might
read it you will not get the sense that
it is a libertarian book it is indeed a
very different kind of approach the
first amendment that you can call
conservative that said I think it might
be worth emphasizing at this moment that
most of the conservatives liberals are
almost all the conservatives liberals
and indeed libertarians that I know
think New York Times versus Sullivan was
rightly decided which is to say that
they don't believe that public figures
should have heightened protection
against libel and they're most of them
on all three camps I think are frankly
appalled to hear successful politicians
suggest otherwise and on that note we
shall go to our questions and answers
please wait raise your hand please wait
to be called upon wait for the
microphone so we can project this out
through the world and you know announce
your name and affiliation unless you
think you have reasons to want to remain
anonymous which I don't think anyone
really does and above all please keep
your comments in the form of a question
if possible this gentleman here thank
you my name is Brett Heinz and I'm with
American University when I went to high
school I went to a private Catholic High
School
so the debates around free speech there
don't quite match the same but I was
wondering if a personal experience that
I've had with censorship I admit
raishin how that would play out in
public schools I was the editor of the
school newspapers up II D section and I
was planning on publishing a editorial
opposing the administration's position
that had tacitly taken on homosexuality
and they demanded that they review the
article before publishing it and
ultimately they took several months with
the review until I left the school
coincidentally but I suppose my question
is that when it comes to school
sponsored speech how does the
administration have the ability to
review what students want to say in
something like a school newspaper in a
public school absolutely in a public
school they would have they can say
we're reviewing everything before it
comes out they can censor it by
eliminating the article altogether by
forcing you to rewrite it by taking
parts out and in fact the case that
created this doctrine was about a school
newspaper that wanted to run actual news
stories not opinion pieces about teenage
pregnancy in the school and about the
impact of divorce on students and the
principle essentially got rid of two
whole pages of the newspaper because he
wanted to get rid of those two articles
at the last minute and the court said
that was okay but it went further it
didn't limit its holding to school
newspapers so while yours was labeled an
opinion piece they might say that either
this was not a topic that was
appropriate for a school-sponsored
newspaper or that the viewpoint was so
provocative within the community that
they never you know I said earlier they
can't really say they were going to
censor it because it's controversial but
that it might be too difficult for some
of the younger students to handle they
would find some pedagogical reason what
where schools go wrong is that they've
gotten sort of lazy they often don't
even bother to come up with a reason
they just say can't publish it then
they'll lose but if they try it can
usually come up with something that's
the sad news I'm actually going
the end of this week to talk to the
annual meeting of the Columbia
scholastic journalism Association which
is the meeting of all of the high school
students who run student publications
and their advisors so I'll probably have
some more stories after that meeting the
woman in the center in the back row so
rude being a moderator you don't know
their names
hi I'm Sarah I'm also from American
University my question for you guys is
well this does seem to be a general
problem across the United States do you
think it should be addressed nationally
or in individual communities that's a
terrific question
as Neil indicated local control is a
very important part of our educational
system elected school boards local
superintendents and as far as I'm able
to grasp the newly crafted law that
replaced No Child Left they had behind
the federal government is stepping back
from giving the kind of guidance they've
been giving for the last 10 years but
the constitutional law is federal law so
we really have to have an interplay
between an understanding of First
Amendment law interpreted by federal
courts and what communities do on the
ground and and one of the
recommendations I make in my book is
that just because the First Amendment
allows schools to engage in certain
kinds of censorship or in to place
certain inhibitions on students speech
doesn't mean that school districts have
to use those powers so one thing that
people who believe in a more a model of
education that emphasizes learning how
to be citizens in an active way might do
is run for school board or go and tell
the school board we would like to be a
community in which the school doesn't
limit students speech
that isn't disruptive even though you
have the power to do that we'd like to
send a different message in this
environment usually the people who talk
up about speech in the local community
or those who would like more censorship
rather than less until there's an
incident and once there's a censorship
incident quite understandably principals
and school boards tend to dig in their
heels rather than to reconsider their
policies so I suggest this is a good
conversation to have before a play has
been cancelled or some other issue has
arisen other questions down here to the
right we'll get both of these gentlemen
hi Michael Enders Washington DC
wondering if any of the courts have
considered the possibility that
educators would be doing well to solicit
provocative speech rather than just
allow it ah I love that idea but I've
never seen a court say it and I don't
know have you ever seen a principal said
well I've seen I've seen some
administrators who profess to encourage
who encourage controversial speech there
is actually a very interesting study
that was published in a book called
controversy in the classroom Hess and
MacAvoy are the two authors and they
actually show their a set of cases in
which classroom teachers are using
controversial topics and controversial
opinions as pedagogical vehicles for
developing city capacity or for
sometimes the writing learning how to
write or for speech and debate purposes
but in the regular classroom not at a
club right and basically they show that
generally speaking I mean this is a very
large study that they did over five
years with thousands of students that
they later also followed up with after
they graduated to see the extent in
which the extent to which they they
remain active citizens right to the
extent to which they vote or participate
in other ways and they do show that when
you encourage and also model
controversial speech in the classroom
for example when you live in a community
where most people for example are very
strong advocates of the Second Amendment
and you come in even if it's not your
view as a teacher right but you come in
and you say here is why we should have
very strict gun control regulations or
the opposite right then basically your
capacity to encourage students to
develop critical thinking skills and
respectful debate skills and all of
these other capacities that allow you to
be a good active efficacious citizens
are really strengthened by this right so
you do see in practice from teachers and
administrators I won't say that this is
the mainstream yeah I would just add
that I think that schools and educators
tend to avoid controversial issues quite
apart from the First Amendment question
because often the school sometimes the
school has a again diverse community
that it's working with and they're just
trying to avoid conflicts that might
give them a hard time
and there was worked by to political
science Berkman and flood sir and it
came out a few years ago now that
they've done subsequent work but that
surveyed biology teachers and they found
that about sixty some percent of biology
teachers soft-pedal evolution or don't
teach it at all mainly because they're
trying or they think mainly because
they're just trying to avoid getting
anybody angry so a lot of avoiding
controversy isn't even about First
Amendment it's to make your life easier
not to aggravate people well teachers
can also lose their
if parents get angry enough in there
yeah and even even if they have tenure
and if they stray from the viewpoint in
the curriculum that the school board has
chosen that can get in a lot of trouble
David's Olsen some years ago I worked
for the Michigan State Legislature and I
worked on a bill to protect the rights
of public schools school students in
publishing newspapers there are plenty
of sources of rights for students
besides the US Constitution each state
has its own Constitution and each state
can pass statewide laws so I'd like to
know has that happened have state courts
relied on state constitutions to protect
students rights have States passed
statutes protecting students rights to
free speech terrific question yes a
number of states have enacted higher
protections for student speech rights
than are currently found in the federal
doctrine from the courts California
basically says the material disruption
standard applies to every kind of
student speech in K through 12
regardless of the Supreme Court
precedence and they also a few years ago
passed a law protecting the advisors to
high school publications going back to
your question about your op-ed piece if
an advisor in California fights to
protect the rights of the student
journalists the statute says they can't
be discharged for that and there are a
number of organizations that are
actively working to try to get more
states to pass more protective laws for
student journalists a number of states
came close to doing it but experienced
vetoes from governor's one case involved
students in a suburb of Chicago at a
very good high school with an
award-winning newspaper who discovered
that there that staff of the school
district had gone on junkets
and they dug out the travel receipts and
showed they stayed you know more days in
the hotel than the meeting went on and
things like that and they weren't
allowed to publish it in the school
newspaper but the Chicago Tribune found
it met all of the standards for
journalists investigations and published
it and after that the Illinois
legislature passed a student rights
statute to cover student journalists and
the governor vetoed it pretty shameful
hmm but but there definitely that is
another place going back to thee is this
a local or a national problem it's both
gentlemen right here
Thank You Lars
Leibler asking this question of my
capacity as a high school basketball
coach at a public school in Fairfax
County I'm wondering whether your
scholarship touches on this issue I've
been following a case that I think is
progressing now there's a football coach
in the state of Washington who over the
course of his career had at the end of
games going to the center of the field
and prayed by himself which apparently
didn't raise a problem some of the kids
on the team then said coach what are you
doing well I'm praying can we join you
of course it's a free country which
people whenever they say that that's
always wrong so as more and more people
joined him for the prayer he then was
suspended and I think that case is
ongoing I'm wondering whether any of
your scholarship and research sort of
touches on that issue it seems like it
only became a problem when the students
came voluntarily to pray with him yes
the last chapter of my book focuses in
in large part on religious expression by
students and one of the problems in this
area is that next to the the doctrine
governing student speech which many
judges sort of throw up their hands and
say this is just too confusing for me
don't know how to use it which you know
they do preside over antitrust in other
very difficult cases but trying to make
it clearer next to that the condition of
the Establishment Clause is an enormous
disarray because the Supreme Court has
basically not relied on a certain old
set of doctrine and hasn't really
replaced it with anything else so
individual justices have their own
approaches but the lower courts don't
have much guidance and so teachers and
principals are confused about what
amounts to an Establishment Clause
violation how does this relate to free
speech for students they too often think
that if students express religious views
like praying over the sandwich I brought
from home not even trying to get other
students to join in that the school will
be accused of an Establishment Clause
violation for allowing this to take
place that is clearly not true the
Supreme Court has repeatedly said that
students have the right to pray in
school again as long as they're not
disrupting class and to express through
speech their religious viewpoints to
each other the problem is when you have
a teacher encouraging people then we
have a question about is participation
really voluntary so the law is pretty
clear this should be from the students
themselves they're very different if a
group of students say you know we've
noticed the coach has been praying in
the middle of the field and we'd like to
do that - do they do it separately do
they join the coach when the coach says
team members whose lives I'm pretty much
in charge of a lot of the time and I'm
very important authority figure to you
you want to join me I think that's a
closer question and certainly if he said
we are going to do this as a team that's
forbidden
gentlemen in the center and we'll have a
couple more
and have to wrap up um Jacob Marx
American University I have kind of quick
scenario question for you if a teacher
is hospitalized due to an incident at a
high school and is assaulted in the
process and that's how she ends up in
the hospital and she posts on Facebook
that she ends up in the hospital and
gets fired because of it is that
violating her First Amendment right I'm
sorry the teacher sorry I wasn't really
clear the teacher was assaulted and an
incident the school and was hospitalized
because of it well in the hospital she
was she posts on a social media site
that she was in the hospital can she be
fired for that it depends part the law
will be different depending where she
lives because the appellate courts are
not entirely in agreement but there are
accepted there are some limits to what
public employees including teachers can
say about their work and so a lot would
depend on whether this was considered a
matter of public concern or not and
hypothetically you know if she were
let's say attacked by a student or by
the school principal that probably to me
would seem like a matter of public
concern but if it was something else
then she probably could be but it's very
hard to say without knowing both more
and where this took place gentleman
right here will be have to be our last
question
dr. McCluskey to your point isn't this
whole issue really more not about a free
expression but but property rights isn't
public property the original sin in this
whole debate where if you you know if
you did not public property public
school the government wouldn't be in the
position to be an arbiter of speech well
I've never put it that way and I'm not
an expert on property law or anything
like that
I do think that
that is certainly a root problem if the
government weren't providing the schools
then most of these issues would go away
now there are a lot of arguments for why
government provide schools that you
could certainly have I think what's
important is we do need to look I think
somewhat below the conflicts themselves
and say well what may be causing us to
have all these conflicts the reality is
I hope we move to school choice we are
moving to school choice to some extent
and that needs means private schools
because even charter schools understand
our public schools so they're still
bound by all this but and well we've
made great progress we're nowhere near
most people going to private schools so
these are very real issues that are
gonna pie have to be dealt with until we
can reach the idea where everybody is
going what I think's ideal to a private
school because then you and the
educators essentially agree on what the
rules are gonna be and that's the best
way to balance lots of competing goods
one where people just put different
values on different things but also
where some things can't coexist together
so you can't have a school that's both
non-religious and that teachers say
religious doctrine which a lot of people
want but in terms of whether or not it's
a public property issue I always have
and I've never framed it that way when
Russell Ross that I met in January when
she was on a panel here one point she
said to me you know outside the First
Amendment I disagree with a lot of
things Cato advocates now of course I
was perplexed because having all the
answers I'm always kind of perplexed
when people disagree with me but there's
a point here that's important we don't
disagree about the First Amendment the
importance of the First Amendment
despite the fact that we are group
disagreed about many policy issues and
in fact at a time I think that's an
important thing to remember in a context
like this at a time when there's lots of
polarization lots of partisanship and
lots of
seemingly intractable conflicts it's
important that people across parties and
across ideologies remain committed and
unified to a strong First Amendment
protections and I think this book
lessons and censorships how schools and
courts subverts citizens First Amendment
rights it's important contribution to
building that kind of unity and to
making us appreciate the importance of
the First Amendment I'd like to thank
professor Ross for coming today
professor Benoit for coming down on a
digitally difficult day to be with us
here and my colleague neal mccluskey for
appearing on the panel most of all on a
rough day oh you must really care about
the First Amendment to come out today
and I appreciate each one of you coming
let's go have lunch and talk more about
this the lunch will be held on the
second level of the jour at the George M
Yeager Conference Center which is up the
spiral staircase in the front of the
building restrooms on the second floor
on your way to lunch look for the yellow
wall and you can purchase your own copy
of lessons and censorship up there
thanks very much
[Applause]
should I have not moved that mic good
evening everybody and welcome to the New
York Academy of Medicine for tonight's
event which is featuring professor
Alondra Nelson speaking on the social
life of DNA for those who don't know me
my name is Lisa Rowe Sullivan and I'm
director of the library here at the
academy and for those of you who don't
know the Academy either we were created
in 1847 and we have a mission to improve
the health and well-being of people in
cities worldwide so urban health really
is our big focus we continue our work
with our elected fellows our Institute
for urban health our current priorities
are health disparities prevention and
healthy aging all critical issues as I'm
sure you'll agree for New York City and
beyond our library has 550,000 volumes
and it's actually one of the country's
great collections it's a very very broad
collection anything you want to know
about health medicine cooking
exploration Natural History we will
probably have it we're open to all and
so we welcome new readers and you can
look at the brochure or speak to one of
the my colleagues outside if you're
interested in learning more why we're
here this evening is because we also
offer public programming that explores
the intersections of health medicine and
the humanities we have in a special
series coming up this year called
changemakers looking specifically at
social justice activism and health but
tonight I'm particularly delighted to be
introducing Alondra Nelson who I
actually first met in Paris on a boat
which was kind of unforgettable slightly
seasick making but not meeting her I'm
just digging a hole now we met in Paris
on a boat and I've said Professor Nelson
is Dean of social science and professor
of sociology and Gender Studies at
Columbia University where she was
formerly the director of the Institute
for Research on women gender and
sexuality she has so many awards and
books that I'm actually gonna have to
read now prior to joining the Columbia
faculty she was on faculty of Yale and
received its Pulver Award for teaching
excellence professor Nelson's research
examines the intersections of science
medicine and inequality and obviously
they're all issues that are very
important to us here at the Academy
which is really nice to have that
connection
professor Nelson's books include
genetics and the unsettled past the
collusion of DNA race and history
Technicolor race technology in everyday
life and body and soul the Black Panther
Party and the fight against medical
discrimination which was recognized with
for scholarly awards she is chair elect
of the science knowledge and Technology
section of the American Sociological
Association and has appeared as an
expert guest with Neil deGrasse Tyson
Startalk
professor Nelson is also a member of the
nsf-funded Council on big data ethics
and society and sits on the editorial
boards of science oh I touched something
how did that happen serve serves on the
Board of Advisors of the data and
society Research Institute you may have
seen her essays reviews and commentary
in The New York Times The Washington
Post Boston Globe and on NPR tonight
she'll be speaking about her most recent
book the social life of DNA race
reparations and reconciliation after the
genome and they are at the back ready
for purchase and signing either now or
after the talk so I hope you enjoy
tonight's evening that I hope you enjoy
tonight's event I should just say as I
need we always need we're not a profit
organization so I need to remind
everyone that what we do depends on the
generosity of sponsors and donors and
there's lots of ways you can get
involved particularly if you're
interested in events like this we have a
Friends of the rare book room there's
more information again in our brochures
outside which supports this kind of
event so having said all that and
tripping over my tongue several times
I'm going to hand us over to please join
me in welcoming professor Nelson to the
stage
we did here that was just this
easy-peasy so thank you all for coming
good evening it's a pleasure to be here
and it's a pleasure to see ELISA who we
indeed met on a boat in Paris it was a
conference dinner it was one of these
touristy things that both of us would
have never done because we were it was
beneath us and in Paris and so we end up
doing it for a conference and it turned
out to be one of the most magical
eventful evenings of my my career for
sure I'm delighted to be here to talk to
you about this new book which is about
medicine per se but I think you'll see
that there's some some obvious
implications for for things that we care
about including racial health
disparities
before I begin I wanted to acknowledge
the historian and journalist Harriet
Washington who's in the audience she's a
dear friend of mine who's the author of
medical apartheid which many of you
probably read and and probably admire as
I do so thank you Harriet for coming so
this book is about a decade of research
I did on genetic ancestry testing I'm a
social scientist and I was interested I
became interested in an Y genealogy as a
social practice what are we trying to do
when we do genealogy and a family
history library or we do it with a
genetic ancestry testing company like
23andme and I came up with some
surprising answers that I'm happy to
have an opportunity to talk to you about
so in 2002 as I was actually finishing
the first draft of the book that would
become my book on the Black Panther
party's health activism I read an
article in the Los Angeles Times
actually in 2000 that was forecasting a
new company that was coming into being
that was going to do genetic testing on
African Americans and would forever
resolve the sort of roots conundrum
right and this article ended by saying
it sounds like something out of Star
Trek my african-americans be able to use
genetics to find out what their ancestry
testing was so this was 16 years ago
right so by mm what mm Family Tree DNA
accompanies some of you are familiar
with starts in the United States it's
the very first us-based
direct-to-consumer genetic ancestry
testing company and by 2002 and 3 you
have a few other companies coming on
board so in 2003
I began ethnographic research I was
looking for people african-americans in
particular who would be interested in
genetic ancestry testing and I had lots
of questions I mean as someone who had
worked on earlier struggles forty four
decades ago around racial health
disparities is one way we might think
about the Black Panthers health activism
and who knew about you know the the sort
of mistrust of medical experimentation
and of the healthcare system that
becomes really heightened in this period
with the revelation of the Tuskegee
syphilis experiment in July 1972 on the
front page of the New York Times I
thought maybe this does sound like
something out of Star Trek but how would
African Americans how would you get off
ricchan Americans to put their DNA and
up to put it in a FedEx envelope and
mail it to a stranger or strange company
what would be the set of incentives that
would that would lead that to come to
pass given that history of medical
apartheid that Harriet writes about so I
wanted to talk to people about this I
also wanted to ask them if they thought
their identities were changing as a
result of this experience and what the
experience meant for them and at this
time unlike today you couldn't it was
difficult to find people who had done
genetic ancestry testing and if you
wanted to find them you had to deal with
conventional genealogists because a lot
of these companies in the early days
knew that the early adopters of genetic
ancestry testing would be conventional
genealogists people already interested
in genealogy
so I began ethnographic fieldwork mostly
at conventional genealogy societies and
clubs and communities I joined the local
chapter here in Harlem of the
afro-american historical and
Genealogical Society and I sort of went
on the road and my travels took me to
the UK to talk to you African America or
to black genealogists there and all
around the United States
so this photograph here is from my
fieldwork this is from 2006 it's a
national meeting of the afro-american
historical and genealogical society in
Massachusetts and this is a moment when
direct-to-consumer genetics companies
and genetic scientists are still trying
to convince African Americans that or
genealogists moreover that genetics
could be useful and their genealogical
pursuits so this is a DNA 101
you see a woman here holding a
double-helix
this is from that same seminar at this
National Convention and the people here
there these have card construction paper
cutouts of the nitrogen bases that are
found in the nucleotides that comprise
DNA so they're learning really the nuts
and bolts way what DNA is so I was my
travels took me there my travels took me
as well to the the the Mormon temple on
128th and Lennox Avenue that some of you
might know Malcolm X Bullard this is the
interior of that which several years ago
about a decade ago started having Black
History Month events in which they
gathered African Americans and people in
the Latter day Saints Church around the
sort of idea that you can't know where
you're going until you know where you've
come from so that has a kind of Appeal
in African American communities and of
course it has a certain kind of appeal
and Mormon cosmology so what did I find
in these first few years of research I
certainly found stories that are
familiar to us that might look familiar
to you from any of the sort of now
myriad direct-to-consumer or genealogy
reality television shows right so
there's two images here from two of skip
gates african-american live series and
then of course from the the TLC series
formerly on NBC called who do you think
you are and these series often show
often celebrities getting information
about their genetic ancestry testing or
often about just their conventional
family history they're often very
emotional and people talk about being
surprised completed and and everything
in between in the emotional spectrum so
I certainly had experiences like that
but I also came to see very early early
on and the research that the genetic
ancestry testing revealed the moment
when people receive the information
became a moment that allowed them entree
into other kinds of social things in the
world ways of using genetic ancestry
testing and the information that it
provides to think about other things in
the world and that's what I'm going to
talk to you about tonight so I call my
this work the social life of DNA
after the work of an anthropologist
named Arjun Appadurai who has published
a book now 30 plus years ago called the
social life of things and he suggested
to us that it was by following things in
motion right that we can illuminate
their human and social context so if I
wanted to understand following a powder
I why genetic ancestry testing was
significant not only for individual
identity and family history but beyond
these things as well perhaps I could do
this by following forms of genetic
analysis around so the social life of
DNA for me means two things it means the
way in which forms of genetic analysis
travel between sites social sites and
domains which I'll say a little bit more
about and the multiple uses to which one
type of genetic analysis is put in this
case genetic ancestry testing which I'll
also say another little bit about so we
tend to think of forms of genetic
testing and analysis in these domains
right so we typically I think
researchers regulatory bodies those of
us as individual consumers often social
scientists distinguish between medical
genetics forensic or criminal justice
genetics ancestry genealogical what we
call recreational genetics and genetic
analysis that might be used in a sort of
family court setting for family
verification or paternity what I found
in the course of talking to people about
genetic testing more generally in
genetic ancestry testing is that the way
that individuals understand genetic
testing really blurs these boundaries
right and that genetics has us so as a
social life and social power because it
has the ability to work sometimes
simultaneously in all of these domains
at once so a woman I call Sarah said to
me we think breast cancer runs in our
family
now that I understand my African
ancestry test which is a genetic
ancestry company that I'll talk about
this evening the difference between the
mother's line and the father's line and
all that I have a better sense of what
the genetic counselor at my doctor's
office was telling me Martin said to me
you know I was never really interested
in genetic science or the genome or
whatever until I heard about these
genetic genealogy tests after I took my
test I wanted to learn everything
genetics I started reading genetics
articles in the newspaper science
magazines
scientific journals and those sorts of
things so what I want to suggest here
just briefly because I want to tell you
more about the the sort of social
travels of the this company that I
studied over a decade
is in fact that one category of genetic
testing often draws Authority from its
association with other forms or domains
of testing and that individuals
experiences or attitudes about one form
of testing inform or legitimate the
broader authority of genetics so for
those of us are interested in health
disparities and in medical genetics in
particular I would want to say that for
African Americans often and for some
communities of color that genetic
ancestry testing becomes a threshold
moment the first moment where people are
thinking about genetics ever so they
might have an experience like Martin
I've never thought about genetics and
now I'm deeply interested in it or
people like Sarah who have an experience
in a clinical or medical encounter that
is informed by her interest and
experience with genetic ancestry testing
which is to say that we need to
understand the full social life right of
DNA and how people think about it in
these various domains if we want to
understand how it's important and how we
can use it with efficacy and a medical
or clinical encounter so following the
social life of DNA I came to understand
that people were using genetic ancestry
testing for these practices that I call
reconciliation projects and for me these
are sites and practices in which genetic
analysis is used to resolve
controversies or answer questions about
the past because I was working with
African Americans more particularly I
was particularly interested and a set of
a subset of reconciliation projects that
were related to perceived injuries
produced by racial slavery and the sort
of resolution of these injuries being
sought through different types of
genetic analysis so how do I go from
genetic ancestry testing identity crying
about ancestors on television to getting
here so I'm gonna go back and tell you a
little bit about how I got here and my
fieldwork this is the tombstone of a
former enslaved man and East Haddam
Connecticut named
venture Smith you
be familiar with if you want broach one
of the few slave narratives that we have
from the era of Plantation slavery his
is quite unique and quite important to
historians because he writes about his
time in the Middle Passage though he
writes about his time on the African
continent he tells us about his family
about the Middle Passage voyage he tells
us that he was on he was carried over to
the Americas on a ship that was helmed
by a captain Collingwood who was very
notorious in historical literature
because he later sort of cast enslaved
Africans off the side of another ship
and during another journey to sort of
save insurance money so we know his
whole story and so it was curious to me
in 2006 that his family gave permission
to the BBC working in collaboration with
some social scientists historians
geneticists and genetic scientists at
UConn to exhume his body and try to do
analysis on his upon his remains to find
out where he comes from so here we have
the case of someone even accounting for
the filter of the person who helped
venture Smith write his slave narrative
but we have the account his full account
in his own words of where he's coming
from and then we have this endeavor to
use genetics to find out where he's
coming from a genetics is supposed to
tell us something more
so certainly genetics could tell us a
few things that are maybe not in his
biography autobiography like what
particular haplotype groups you know he
belongs to and these sorts of things but
it still struck me as a kind of curious
endeavor so I spent some time a couple
of different occasions going to an event
called venture Smith day that happens at
the Congregational Church in East Haddam
Connecticut his family knows so much
about him and each other that they
gather annually in the fall in this town
and this in this green just next to this
church and they lay a wreath on his
grave
this is his gravesite here a member of
his family and they come from California
and other parts of Connecticut all
across the country and I asked some of
the matriarch of the family two of the
eighth generation descendants about you
know why the family permitted the sec
summation and what the information they
thought
we're gonna get so one woman said to me
I think it will help school children I
wanted to help American schoolchildren
another person explained one of his
descendants explained that she hoped it
would bring healing so I thought this
was quite poignant we're doing genetic
ancestry testing not for identity
information but because we think that
genetic ancestry testing or genetic
analysis of these remains can do
something to provide healing for our
country and for this family so this is
where I began to really think about
following genetic ancestry testing in
the various social ways that it was used
so I talked to lots of people dozens and
dozens of people over the last decade
many of these people use many different
companies some of you might be genetic
genealogist here and you probably may
view several different companies and so
you know I made a very difficult
decision to write really about one
company and the use of one companies
test for reasons I think will become
clear to you by the time I finish which
was a tough decision but but I ended up
writing about the African ancestry
company so this is the fourth genetic
ancestry company to emerge in the United
States it starts in 2003 and it's the
only first and only black owned company
so it was started co-founded by this
gentleman here an African American
geneticist named Rick Kittles who's been
at various institutions he had been at
Howard University Ohio State the
University of Illinois at Chicago and
now he's at the University of Arizona
and he's a prostate cancer researcher
and he's an entrepreneur on the side so
he starts this company in 2003 with an
african-american woman a business
partner and economist with a and the
degree in economics from Stanford named
Gina page and they are an interesting
company because you know that question
about mistrust it's in part answered and
of course embodied in the very physical
body of Rick Kittles but also because
the company went out of its way when
they were sort of advertising their
wares at these various kinds of
conventions to really say to African
Americans where the company you can
trust where the company we can trust
because we know about the experience of
these historical issues of
experimentation
where the company you can trust because
we don't keep the sample so all the
companies claim to throw out the tissue
but they actually don't keep any of the
data as well right this could be a
company worth I think a lot more money
if they were keeping all this data over
time so this company yields as an output
to its customers a certificate of
ancestry this is one for a gentleman
who's told that he's inferred to be
related to the Temne people of Sierra
Leone so this is the individual identity
piece and I found that but people I
spoke to did lots of interesting things
I mean some of them sort of got the
certificate of ancestry sort of shrugged
their shoulders and put it in a box
somewhere some people framed it and put
it in a prominent place in their home
and you know various things in between
people shared it with family members
they became sort of an object of
scrutiny and curiosity and pleasure at
family reunions so the certificate does
a lot of work although the letter that a
consumer receives will say often that
based on these you know the markers that
we are testing sort of are found in a
couple of different places right but the
preponderance of the marker we're going
to put on their certificate so there was
more complexity in that so I follow
these genetic ancestry tests of this
particular company and a set of
exercises that I call reconciliation
projects I'm not going to be able to
talk about the African burial ground
monument today but I'll just say in
brief I mean maybe we can talk about
this in QA and brief that Rick Kittles
the African American geneticist I showed
you earlier begins his career as a
junior scientist working on the African
burial ground research project in the
mid 1990s and it's here based on using
developments by sort of the geneticist
Brian Sykes who had a very important
paper in nature in the 1990s about how
to begin to work with ancient DNA
samples that were sort of decomposing
that he comes up with you know an idea
to create using samples gathered from
all over the world using them GenBank
and other sorts of sources a reference
database of african DNA and then to the
extent that they could get from these
remains that were close to 200 years old
any sort of information they were going
to match them against this reference
database to get what they were calling I
would
researchers than were calling the macro
ethnic affiliations of the people that
were buried there so this model becomes
the African ancestry company to great
controversy on some parts so and the
sort of account